conférences débats ou encore séances de
dédicaces après une édition virtuelle
l'année dernière auteur comme
participants sont heureux de se
retrouver au salon histoire de lire qui
se déroulait cette année dans quatre
lieux emblématiques de versailles je
viens chaque année parce que l'histoire
m'intéresse énormément je lis beaucoup
de livres d'histoire et c'est
intéressant de pouvoir rencontrer les
auteurs et de voir l'actualité des
publications des auteurs que je connais
que j'ai envie de rencontrer et puis que
je revois régulièrement d'ailleurs qui
viennent tous les ans et puis c'est
l'occasion aussi de découvrir des livres
que voilà par par surprise ce retour à
la fois grâce à l'écriture voire d'avoir
des retours de lecteurs et puis deux et
puis sur les planches en même temps suit
non je passe une rentrée très belle le
salon histoire de lire c'est une
manifestation qui a lieu depuis une
quinzaine d'années à versailles dans la
mairie dans la l'hôtel du département la
préfecture dans plusieurs lieux de la
ville et s'y rassemblent environ 150 180
auteurs avec un point commun qui est
l'histoire lecteurs passionnés ou
simples curieux le salon s'est attiré un
large public du roman historique à la
bande dessinée en passant par l'essai et
même la présentation de jeux de société
il y en a pour tous les goûts réseau
permet de s'approprier l'histoire de la
résistance de ses actions et des dangers
rencontrés par les résistants dans
toutes les opérations qu'ils ont pu
mener sur le territoire de l'ancienne
seynoise ce qui est amusant c'est que je
rencontre d'anciens étudiants des
parents dont six aux étudiants mais
aussi des passionnés d'histoire pour
cette 14e édition des habitués du salon
mais aussi de nouveaux visages des
comédiens amoureux d'histoire se sont
invités au salon pour une au solo
francis huster ou encore philippe
torreton ont pu mettre en scène des
écrits d'histoire c'est l'histoire d'un
jeune homme jean fournier qui qui
qui va mettre beaucoup de temps à mettre
la guerre de 14 enfin derrière lui et à
pouvoir retrouver une certaine raison de
vivre justement c'est versailles les
auteurs le disent les lecteurs sont
heureux de discuter d'un sujet d'un
livre avec avec l'auteur et ensuite de
repartir avec une dédicace un salon qui
a récompensé trois youtuber d'histoire
en amont pour la quatrième année de quoi
se mettre à la page pour un salon qui
entend toucher un public encore plus
jeune dans les années à venir